hey georgie
i'm thinking about taking your meemaw
away for this weekend
mocha you had my blessing thank you
and i was wondering maybe if you'd look
after squirrel while i'm gone
you saying i'm the manager oh i'm saying
i want you to look after the store
while i'm gone but in a managerial
capacity
you think you can handle it yes sir i
will make you proud
great can i fire people no
can i get paid more no can i at least
change the music we play here
what's wrong with the music we play
nothing it's just kind of grandpa music
well how is this grandpa music do you
listen to it
yeah do you have grandchildren yeah
do you see where i'm going with
there you this i hope you enjoyed your
shopping experience i did
i'd let the manager know but he already
does because it's me
i'll take it it's been a pleasure to
serve you
you might want to slow down we don't
have a license to sell guns in here
[Music]
just kidding it's texas we got them in
the back
didn't feel at all that's how good this
helmet is i'm gonna take a whack
try it on i'll be up front when you're
ready to bite
[Music]
i like to report a robbery
[Music]
well before i tell you my name is there
any way we can do this where the owner
of the store don't find out
because he left me in charge and i
really screwed up
at least four hundred dollars
well i know it's a lot that's why i said
i screwed up
i gotta think about this i'll call you
back
[Music]
what the hell i locked this
who's here i'll call the cops it's just
me
why are you back so soon none of your
business
how'd it go yesterday it was good
until it wasn't what do you mean
i was helping a customer and i guess i
forgot to close the register
cause when i got back to it all the
money was gone
are you kidding me i screwed up did you
call the police
i didn't want to get him involved but i
was gonna make it right
here take it
so we good you're fired
really get out of my store
now
[Music]
so
you